INTERVIEWER: Divorced
and left on her own
with three small children to
care for, Kelley Lewis decided
to turn her life
around and literally
rebuild it with her bare hands.
When you got divorced,
you had three small kids.
Can you tell me about what you
were going through mentally
and emotionally?
KELLEY LEWIS: Things were
not in my life going the way
that I had hoped, career-wise,
relationship-wise, personally.
And that is when I dealt with
my most severe depression
and having medical
attention to address that.
I'm 29.
I know I have three children,
but I'm still just 29
and this doesn't
have to be the end.
And so that's when
I made the decision
to buy a piece of land.
And I just started
doing more research
and came across this
whole tiny house movement.
And I just thought that was so
fascinating, because again, I
came back to what is
the most important to me
and finding that
meaning for myself.
Come on in.
INTERVIEWER: It's so cool.
It's so tiny.
KELLEY LEWIS: It is.
INTERVIEWER: How
big is actual space?
KELLEY LEWIS: It's
192 square feet.
12 feet wide by 16 feet long.
INTERVIEWER: And this is a
work in progress obviously.
KELLEY LEWIS: Most definitely.
Most definitely.
INTERVIEWER: How long have
you been building this?
KELLEY LEWIS: Third
summer, so two years.
INTERVIEWER: Aside
from the framing,
the shell of the house, have
you done everything else
on your own?
KELLEY LEWIS: Yes.
Mm-hmm.
Everything from
insulation-- I did
have someone come
in and do electric
and show me how to do that.
But everything
else has been done
and I've had friends come help
me, and family help me, and--
INTERVIEWER: And your kids?
KELLEY LEWIS: --And
my kids have helped.
INTERVIEWER: What are some
of the bigger challenges
that you faced
building the house?
KELLEY LEWIS: The design
part was a challenge.
There was no computer.
There was nothing.
I literally used a ruler and
pencil with a good eraser
and designed it as I went.
And I ended up hiring
someone to build the shell,
and then I've taken
it from there.
Watching YouTube videos on
how to install things or make
things, from a
composting toilet,
to a wood-burning stove
chimney, and things
that keep you off grid.
Lot of the things
that I've used,
such as the windows,
and doors, and the stove
have all been
recycled materials.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KELLEY LEWIS: I think
a lot of people,
especially in today's
society, always want more.
And something bigger and better
and I'm guilty of it too.
But it if it takes away from
you appreciating the smaller
things and things
that you do have,
I think that's where
there's a disservice.
INTERVIEWER: What has
that meant for you
to be able to build this
cabin with your children?
KELLEY LEWIS: Kids tend
to stereotypically learn
these types of things from
a dad or from a male figure
but they're learning
that from their mom.
And they get to see
nature in the process.
And I think that's really cool.
INTERVIEWER: What do you think
this house symbolizes to you?
KELLEY LEWIS: Well it started
as a symbol of a new beginning.
However, it's become
something more.
It's a rebuilding of a life.
Everything from
every screw or nail
that's been put into the cabin
has some sort of symbolic story
and meaning for me.
Looking back, would
I change anything?
And I don't think I would.
I'm a stronger person for
it and by being a stronger
person myself will allow
me to be a stronger teacher
and create stronger children.
INTERVIEWER: Be sure to
check out this next episode.
Two years of trash in
this tiny little jar.
SPEAKER: My values are
having a really low
environmental impact.
I have to live like I want that.
And so that's why I decided
to change my lifestyle.